I want to make a bet with you today yes
a bet I'm gonna bet you by the time
you're done watching this video one of
two things gonna happen - either you can
have tears coming down your eyes you're
gonna cry
we're gonna have to choose all of your
body cuz that's what happens I mean if
it does if you do cry and if you do get
the chills all of your body I want you
to text five people this story this link
and if you don't tweet me any question
I'll respond back to you fair enough
this is a story about a horse and if you
don't know I love horses I love
everything about horses I love horse
movie Secretariat Seabiscuit champ with
John Boy back in the days I probably
watched John Boyd 50 times in Iran until
I finally met John Woo it's just a very
emotional movie to me I love horse
paintings I love growing a racetrack I
love going to the Derby I love going to
Kentucky Derby I love horses but this is
a story about an owner and a horse he
didn't believe in it's a story of an
owner named Isaiah yet and this is a man
very wealthy man he's been in a horse
business for a very very long time and
every year horse owners go to this
auction and they bet on horses and they
buy horses now is that yet who I believe
is an Egyptian millionaire
he not only buys forces he also sells
his own horses
so in this auction he sold one of his
horses he just didn't believe this horse
was gonna do good so he gave it up to
auction so everybody these millionaires
they bring different analysts these are
people that calculate which horse is
gonna do good based on certain data that
they pull up right and so this guy
brings a guy named Jeff now Jeff for you
to know he's very decked out very
educated brilliant guy he's a guy that
was in Wall Street did very well in his
mid late 20s and then he got bored he
says like I love horses I'm just gonna
get into the horse business and he came
out with a formula on how to pick
winning horses and it's very different
than some of the other people are they
picked their horses sure it's okay go at
it let me know which horse I should bet
on says great so Jeff goes and starts
doing his investigation and by the way
these horses don't have names they're
typically year old and they have numbers
like it's not gonna be certain name
you're gonna do number 86 number 129
that's what you're buying your binding
number right so Jeff goes and does his
due diligence and it comes back and say
it says okay so who should I buy he says
uh there's not a single horse for you to
buy today he says what do you mean and
that one horse there's not a single
horse that's worth the investing money
it's just about that
horse with a great pedigree waste of
time don't do it so what do I do
he says look I think the best horse for
you to bet on this year for the Derby
Derby is the horse you put up for
auction
he says wait a minute the horse that I'm
selling that I sold yes do you want me
to buy back my own horse that's like
comical yes you got to go back and buy
that horse it's kind of weird
why do you say that let me explain - why
should they pull up the data and here's
the data he's dead horse just so you
know when it came to height he was in
the 56 percentile of height you know
what that means you know how parents go
to the doctor and doctor says your
four-year-old son is in the 89th
percentile what does that mean out of
100 kids he's gonna be taller than 89 of
them this horse was in the 56 percentile
when it came down to the weight he was
in the 61 percentile light horse short
horse when he came down to pedigree
ready
70% ah nothing impressive but Jeff
Telles I yet when it comes down to his
heart's left ventricle ready ninety nine
point six one percentile let me see this
again ninety nine point six one
percentile that means out of a thousand
horses only three of them have a bigger
left ventricle you got a bet on this
horse cuz he's got a big heart and he's
gonna fight and when you race you need a
horse with a big heart if you understood
oh my gosh I hope you're right and make
sense cuz a lot of open lot all these
you know predictive analytics they like
to look at guys would be horses with big
nostrils I says no no no it's all about
the left ventricle so it gets this horse
you know what he ends up naming this
horse doing that he bought back the one
that he didn't believe in ready American
Pharoah you know what American throw
does in 2015 American flora does in 2015
something that no horse had done for 39
years American Pharoah goes and wins the
Triple Crown second fastest time ever
not only that American Pharoah wins the
Breeders Cup that same year never been
done before not only does he win the
Breeders Cup he wins by six and a half
lengths now what does this have to do
with anything
this was a special horse butt pad I mean
that's great that he won all that stuff
what's your point in 2006 two
billionaires fought for one horse
because that horse had such great height
weight pedigree everybody wanted to
source great pedigree you know what they
paid for that horse 16 million dollars
you can go to your own research 2006
most expensive horse ever bought an
option you'll see 16 million dollars do
you know what that horses courier
earnings was ever-ready
ten thousand dollars sixteen million
dollars ten thousand dollars what does
this have to do with you everything see
back in 2009 I was in a meeting and I'll
never forget this
the chairman the company got up and he
said every ten years I picked somebody
that I believe is gonna be the future of
the industry and I Bank on him for a
decade and everyone sitting in the room
it wasn't a lot of people that were
waiting to see what name was gonna be
mentioned the names were brought up
wasn't my name i sat in that room and I
said Wow
you picked the guy that played
professional sports for college you
picked the guy that is American I'm
Middle Eastern I don't have a degree I
never played organized sports
you picked the guy that looked the part
you picked the guy that everything made
sense good pedigree everything was
proper but he never sought a heart
you never sought a character I said no
problem do you know how many times I
replayed that talk in my own mind so
many times you know why see why you're
watching this some of you may be saying
I wish I was taller I wish had better
skin I wish I had nicer eyes I wish my
nose was smaller I wish I was a little
bit stronger I wish I was a better
communicator I wish had a better degree
I wish my parents were Kennedy's or the
Rockefellers or the Vanderbilts I don't
know I just wish my parents had a name I
mean I wish I had those contacts I wish
my parents did something with their
lives see those things don't matter what
matters is what nobody sees and it's
right here that's your left ventricle
it's
heart people can't see this everybody
sees degrees everybody sees height
everybody sees last name nobody sees the
heart I'm in my garage right now it's
12:30 Sunday night kids are sleeping
upstairs you can see the light just went
off you know why because I don't want to
make a lot of noise these kids are
asleep I got to go to school early in
the morning you know what I think about
all the time as I'm chasing and I'm
going after my vision of what I want to
do I think about that heart no one knows
your heart so as you're watching this
and you're a little bit down on yourself
maybe not everything's going right do
not let the world judge you on the
outside go show the world what's on the
inside and by the way if you get the
chills and if you got tears in your eyes
right now pay your bed text this to five
other people because I bet there's other
people that also need to hear this
message and if I lost send me a tweet
I'll answer any question may have but
either way have a killer week this week
love you